how's the dad life treating you now I
mean how's your kid now like two life of
great yeah no [__] no it wasn't it I
feel like he had like a baby the last
time I saw you yeah he 11 boys oh [__] I
did see you like about a year ago yeah
he was still in the womb okay okay so
interview a lot of people well I've
interviewed you three times since the
pandemic yeah yeah so were you gonna get
tired of me no you're fine I feel like I
should be like one of those because I'll
be seeing a lot of dudes going on the
podcast and be doing the interview was
like hella like they'd be doing like
them they what the [__] do that [__] be
I don't know I don't even know what you
just said like listen when you know you
know those guys like like like
um that go on podcasts and do like a
like you know how Boosie going on
[__] Vlad 24 7. so so boozy I feel
like it was on Vlad every two weeks what
the [__] is that I think because Vlad is
uh it's a business relationship they
have hey well come on let's if we could
do this [__] bro so so Vlad and boozy at
this point I feel like vlad's like our
Oprah now yeah like anything going on in
the world just wait a couple of weeks a
Vlad interview will drop and boozy will
tell you okay yeah yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying we can get this [__] rolling
yeah I know I'm not confrontational so
that wouldn't work with me right yeah I
hate confrontation confrontation is not
good yeah no and I feel like like you
got to be like
you got it you got to be cool with that
[__] well I think like
yeah I mean they want you to talk about
everything everything yeah I don't got
that [__] at me I I respect it yeah um I
was gonna say with your kid though like
okay 11 months old yeah so that means
he's like borderline walking
um yeah he's getting around climbing on
[__] like like if you like put him on at
the he can pull himself up on the couch
so he's he's mobile yeah yeah he's
getting around on the ground and [__]
yeah hell yeah yeah he's getting down is
it a lot because obviously tour is
coming is gonna be pretty hard for you
to take a a significant break or is he
coming on the road with you
um oh damn I hung up my phone call that
back uh but yeah he he gonna come on the
road he's gonna come on the road yeah
just a little bit yeah not too much you
got some wild fans man yeah yeah yeah
but the good thing is they are females
that is a good thing yeah that would be
kind of a wonderful thing to have like
I just dealt with um like the toxic side
of Little Dirk's fan base yeah and it's
like a lot of oh you [__] what you do
all I did was say this was like you
always wait who is wait wait wait okay
so you know how we started this
interview and listen yes we started this
interview and we said you finally got a
real hit
oh wait wait oh me you said you finally
got a really you know what I seen what
you said all I said was I seen what you
said he has yet to get a real thing what
you said and mind you now [__] oh so
listen now he has one yeah right yeah
but his fans are [__] weirdos what
they say they're like little white dudes
like with OTF tattoos who swear they're
from like oh block but they're from like
[__] Scranton Pennsylvania or some
[__] and they're just in my [__] DMs
like going crazy right so it's like at
least you don't have those like at least
it's just females you know yeah I damn
yeah I seen what you said though but I
wasn't wrong it'd be like if I told you
a year ago yo you got plaques but you
ain't caught a hit hit yet I'll be like
yeah that's true right but now you got
one now you got it you got a [__] hit
bro yeah finally I mean after like after
15 years of making music I have no I'm
rich who are we calling on the phone on
the interview now
yeah mute it though but yeah though man
now I gotta make sure my girl straight
because she at work and she about to
leave work
you know I don't know you know you're
[__] Rich right yeah yeah I mean yeah
you'll be like staying home here yeah no
I almost deaf all right it's coming is
that coming soon sure you guys get
married she don't want to stop though I
respect that that's a problem that's a
good thing because she wants to have her
own [__] yeah you know most women yeah
would be like hey I'm chilling yeah you
know nah she was she she
um
she's just she she don't she won't work
does your lady deal with uh the fan
fandom pretty well she probably knew
what she signed up for it's not like
this is new yeah yeah
you see each other have you ever had a
stalker
no not really like nobody pulled to the
hotel room follow you on like like
[__] City yeah yeah I had that I had
that yeah I had a lot of that uh
yeah I'd have had that but it won't it I
don't really pay no mind to it though
right it's never like stalker like bad
stalker like following me everywhere
knowing I'm gonna be like every second
like
because we won't play that [__] right
yeah it won't play that [__] how many
female fans have your face or your
lyrics or your logo tattooed on your on
their body is it a lot now oh that's a
few that's a lot it's like north of 100
like 2C or two times or like yeah north
of 100 yeah north of 100 ways north of
North I might be close to a thousand a
thousand women running around here yeah
it might be close to a thousand that
because they show up they show up to the
concert with the time I mean I hope so
yeah especially this tattoo the broken
heart oh man do they get any sort of
like hey here's like a you know like a
fan fan pack or something I'm gonna take
a picture with you you'll take a picture
yeah we're gonna take a picture and I'll
probably sign something for you yeah of
course
I can't imagine how weird it'd be to
like meet a human being who likes like
hey look we have matching tattoos or
this is you this is you and then it's
not me but it's like the tattoo artist
was terrible terrible oh my God
yeah I'd be like is that me
um all right so uh 21 Savage Khalid
future won't be on the final version on
the deluxe but who is there anybody else
on the album no no that's it I don't
really like features like that yeah
you're not a big feature guy I don't
really got many friends man you always
say that you don't have like a lot of
music industry fans no look how I pull
up with the listen you're gonna see me
here with the same people every time how
like how often are you saying no to like
you getting on other rappers records
because you gotta be in high demand
every day yeah we saying know the
features every day like I just saw uh I
spice did a song with Taylor Swift like
if Taylor Swift calls you saying yes
hell yeah you got to do that yeah it
makes sense yeah yeah it makes sense if
it's something that makes sense if
Morgan Wallen Morgan Wallen you could
get Morgan Wallen bro if I can't get
Morgan well then I will give him all you
got to do is say
first of all ask them not saying that
and if he says no I'm not saying that
I'm not doing that